this podcast has bad words hey hey
everybody quick note before we dive into
this or maybe just a quick monitoring on
a bit because it has been it's been a
heck of a year it's been a heck of the
last month or so and I feel so like good
exhausted it's that it's that tired you
feel after you've worked out really hard
at the gym or my doctor dragged me to a
SoulCycle class recently and by the end
of that you're just like you're dripping
in sweat but you feel like oh man that
45 minutes or an hour or what seemed
like 10 hours was totally worth it and I
think I sort of have this metaphysical
sweat going on I know Ryan does too by
the way I'm recording this we just got
back to Los Angeles or I should say me
and and podcast Sean is in the room here
with me we were just in Dayton Ohio for
a week and man that trip was amazing we
were filming some stuff for our new
documentary so our new documentary is
built around this talk that we've given
over the last year we visited 50 cities
in the United States and Canada
Australia and New Zealand we gave this
talk over and over and over and then we
also film that talk in front of a couple
live audiences in this beautiful
warehouse space in Los Angeles and so we
gave the talk I'd seen about 40 minutes
or so we're gonna build the next
documentary around that talk in order to
do that we're doing some different
monologues and some different interviews
and some backstories and b-roll about
consumerism and meaning and crisis and
and these sort of tipping points or
these these moments of pivoting in our
own lives so we're diving deep into the
back stories of of Joshua and Ryan
before they were the minimalist before
we were the minimalist it's weird to
talk about myself in the third person
there but really diving in to the the
Dayton Ohio backstory and there's sort
of this this crisis of meaning that's
going on there and it's like this
perfect metaphor for consumerism in a
way the the results of consumerism well
it actually the the the best metaphor
was we were just in this plate as this
space called the Dayton arcade and the
Dayton arcade
it's downtown Dayton it was built in
1904 and Ryan and I we got permission to
spend some time there because it closed
in 1990 so almost 30 years ago now it
was just a few blocks from the first
house I lived in as a kid and I remember
going there a few times and have these
very distant memories of being there and
it's this old shopping center but it's a
mixed-use place as well that meaning
there were housing developments there
office space and in 1990 it was
shuttered and has been shuttered for the
last 30 years it's its last iteration
though was well they were trying to turn
it into a more traditional shopping mall
and you see the remnants of it now the
bones of this place are beautiful but
when you try to take this thing of
beauty and turn it into this this
consumerist temple a sort of Cathedral
of consumerism well then the result is
is this emptiness and I think many of us
are experiencing this emptiness in our
lives as well and so we really wanted to
dive deep into that now Ryan and I have
spent the last year on the road we just
finished up a month in Australia and New
Zealand and I'll tell you some of those
were some of the best events that we've
ever had and the podcast you're about to
hear in fact we dragged someone on to
the podcast a guy who never does well
very rarely does interviews in fact this
was his first public appearance in three
years and it was his first interview it
wasn't really an interview we just had a
conversation on stage but it was his
first sort of interviewed format in over
two years his name's Derek Siver's he
wrote a great book called anything you
want you probably know him from his TED
Talks and a bunch of other stuff that
he's done we actually talked about that
in the podcast itself so I won't belabor
the points we'll put links to everything
we talked about in the show notes as
well but during our time in Australia
and New Zealand it was like the end of
that that workout the end of the the
soul cycle session now Ryan and I have
gone out on eight tours and this is our
eighth year now five of those tours have
been
prolonged tours and I keep telling
myself you know what I've learned my
lesson
this is it and then of course a year
later I'm like I'm ready to get back out
and go on tour and that's because I find
so much value from getting out there and
interacting with people and answering
questions but also asking questions and
seeing what questions resonate what
stories resonate what sort of material
resonates with people so I can go back
and use that as sort of creative
inspiration and the writings that we do
or the films that we do or now though
the podcasts that we do having that
material and be able to flesh it out and
and update my ideas as time goes on
because the things that I thought were
profound or even meaningful when I was
28 years old almost a decade ago now
when I first found minimalism then those
ideas need to be updated they're they
are not static they're they're
ever-changing and bending and stretching
and and contracting and I want to be
able to see how that actually applies to
the real world not just in a a ivory
tower or Russia in our new studio space
now it's it's not ivory at all it's a
great hour I suppose we're here in Los
Angeles and and what I've realized is
that I can over stretch myself in that
experience so too much growth can be
irresponsible and stretching myself too
far can be irresponsible because it
actually takes away from my health or my
creativity and so while we've come to
the end of this year of just beautiful
experiences I also realized that it was
too much and so I think going forward
you're gonna notice a few things from
the minimalist one is it's not to say we
won't ever do live events in the future
we certainly will I don't see any
protracted touring in our future for the
foreseeable future
now again I'm obviously open to changing
that at some point in time but I could
see if we do a tour in the future it
being a much more concise version in
fact the the one we did in 2016 was for
our documentary minimalism we did a
theater tour with that and I think we
did 15 cities in a month that's a lot
more palatable I could see I could see
in fact just doing maybe a one week two
or a two-week tour in the future at some
point but we're taking a long break at
this point this is our time to sort of
after the soul cycle class or after the
gym where where you have to recover this
is the recovery period that allows us to
create something meaningful that next
meaningful thing we hope for it to be
our our second documentary will link to
some stuff in the show notes you can see
some behind the scenes photos of that
Dayton arcade experience it was it was
truly astonishing it was beautiful and
there was a lot of sort of despair there
at first but through that despair there
was a lot of hope actually I think the
hope is birthed out of the despair and
and actually I think you'll see that
that with spaces like that we can
reclaim them and there's this this wreck
this reclamation period where we can
move forward towards something more
meaningful that thing that was
meaningless
we can we can find something that is
meaningful I mean when I say to live a
meaningful life I really mean to find
experiences that are meaningful that
propel us forward during this short time
that we have here on earth and so we're
all searching for meaning that was the
commonality of the 50 cities that we've
been to we have factory workers and CEOs
and executives and college students and
high school students and
great-grandparents and black and white
and red and yellow and people from all
different socioeconomic backgrounds
they're all asking the same thing it's
how do I live a more meaningful life and
I think it manifests differently with
different value systems and different
beliefs but ultimately we're trying to
determine how do I live a more
meaningful life and many of us have
learned that this constant barrage of
consumerism is doing the opposite it's
getting in the way it's taking away from
the joy and the the the purpose the the
sense of meaning that we have in our
lives so we turn to these pacifiers like
consumerism like endless hours of
watching TV or or just browsing social
media for many hours on in or even worse
we turn to alcoholism or drug abuse the
the opioid crisis is real
being back in Dayton Ohio you know it's
the it's the overdose capital of America
right now our Montgomery County is where
Dayton is but birthed out of that
despair I think there's a potential for
hope and I see so many great things
going on there in in Dayton Ohio that
that weren't going on or maybe they were
just under the surface that were just
starting to happen right before we left
eight and we left sort of at the nadir
it was it was the end of of 2012 and I
lived downtown and I can tell you that
sometimes I felt like I might be the
only resident of a city that has a
million people and in the greater metro
area and that's because you know a lot
of the jobs had laughs a lot of the
people would left the city but now you
see people coming back you see
businesses coming back you see diversity
you see a different cultural perspective
you see conversations you see new
restaurants and coffee shops and and
these new community centers and the arts
and occupancy downtown now is 95 percent
I couldn't even imagine that five or six
years ago but that tells me that very
quickly when you get people working
together and and they find meaning in
what they're doing they can make some
pretty great changes and so throughout
the the exploration of the last year
we've recorded a lot of live events and
and I know we went we're not able to put
all those in our feed and we actually
prefer to do the in studio episodes
because well because the dynamic is a
bit different the live events don't
always translate as well on audio
although I'll tell you some of my
favorite podcasts that we've ever
released through the minimalist podcasts
or like the events we did in Calgary and
and Edmonton for example those two were
just like I felt outstanding about those
it's going to go back and listen to them
their episodes 102 and 103 and I
remember like they're just these peak
times there are other times where the
content or the conversations are good
but they're often too repetitive they
might be repeating the same thing that
we said the night before or more
frequently it's just that the live audio
or the live events lend themselves to
being better in front of the live
audience themselves and then of course
you you you have some bit of loss of
context when you publish it in an audio
feed obviously the quality even though
podcast Shawn does a great job of
recording live events if you're not in a
podcast studio you're not in a recording
space it's not going to sound as good as
as what you're hearing right now because
we're in a space that is set up
specifically for this for talking into a
microphone and soon to be talking in
front of cameras as well so real quick
thanks to all of our patreon supporters
because as soon as we reach that in the
next level because we don't do any
advertisements on the podcast we're
gonna have a video version of this
podcast ideally it'll be the summer when
that happens so a lot more in studio
stuff coming in fact this might be the
last live podcast you hear in our feed
maybe maybe ever
or maybe just for a long time what I
would like to do is release at least one
more event from our our tour in
Australia two of my favorite events of
all time were Sydney and Melbourne we
did it was like everything was firing on
all cylinders that's the other weird
thing about going out on tour it's by
the time you get to the end of it you
get to city 47 or 48 of a 50 city tour
and you're like wow I feel like I'm
finally ready to go out on tour and that
happened even when we did 15 cities
you're getting 10 cities or 12 cities
into it you're like okay I'm finally in
some sort of rhythm some sort of pattern
I'm ready to go out there but of course
it doesn't work that way you grow
immensely through the process but none
of the events are ever perfect but I
know a lot of you do find value in these
live events so if you do want to hear
them we will eventually release every
live event that we've recorded as long
as there are any sort of technical
difficulties or audio issues but we
release any of them to our patreon
supporters every week we do a separate
podcast it's called the minimalist
private podcast and each week we release
a postscript episode so we answer one or
two or sometimes three additional
questions that were covered in the main
episode we dive a little bit deeper we
let our hair down because well there's
only a few thousand people supporting us
on
on that feed so it allows us to be we're
always all thin thick with what we're
talking about but it also allows us to
to dive deeper in a way that the people
have been following along with this
narrative for a while can can understand
we don't have to recover the the same
ground so we do that each week but we're
also releasing these live events so the
live event you're about to hear right
now if you want to hear similar ones
we've already released quite a few on
the podcast the private podcast and you
get that podcast feed right there in
your normal podcast feed so say you're
listening to this on Apple podcasts or
you listen to it on overcast or feedly
or wherever you listen to podcast you
can listen to our private podcast it
just shows up separately you need this
this private link that will send you if
you are a supporter of the podcast and
that support none of that money goes to
me or Ryan not that it matters we're not
allergic to making money but that money
is to pay for the studio space that
we're in to pay having a full-time
producer eventually pay for cameras and
and and having a full-time filmmaker
film it so we can do the video version
of the podcast which you'll be able to
subscribe to over on on our YouTube
channel
but that money doesn't go to us but it
allows us to keep this a hundred percent
advertisement free and so what we'll do
is we'll continue to release over time
one a month probably maybe even more if
we do more live events well release
those live events so you still have
access to them it's recorded somewhere
exclusively for our patreon supporters
so if you want to support us head on
over to the minimalists com click donate
at the top if you become a patron then
of course you'll have access to all the
PostScript episodes all of the live
events that we release from here on now
also the entire back catalog of all the
PostScript episodes there are dozens of
them at this point also the the catalog
of previous live events that we've
already released and then we also do a
monthly live stream called ask the
minimalists anything that's a video live
stream that we do but we also record the
audio of that and put out the audio
version on the minimalist private
podcast as well so that's in summary
basically all I'm saying here is we're
done touring for a while I'm sure we'll
have some sort of events in in the
future but no more protracted tours
but the reason being is because we want
to focus on continuing to produce
meaningful creations whether that's
writing podcasts or films we're really
focused on that we don't want perpetual
touring to get in the way of that but we
still want to see you so we'll do events
in the future we want to hang out we
want to say hi we want to answer your
questions we want to ask you questions
we want to identify what is resonating
with you and and and what isn't I really
hope you enjoy this deep dive that we
had here with Derek Siver's it's the it
was the weirdest strangest venue I think
we did all tours Sean would you agree
with that yes he's he's given me the
face that says it was certainly strange
it was that a well actually I think we
talked about a little bit on the podcast
itself so I won't run it for you but it
was it was a strange space it was I'll
leave it at that I hope you enjoy this
live podcast I know I certainly did well
Ryan and I had the privilege of speaking
with a guy who was so influential to us
I hope you find value in it as well his
name is Derek Siver's all right we'll
see you soon
hello New Zealand
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus live in Auckland man Adelaide
killed that come on man I said we're
live in Auckland there we go yo you're
just in Adelaide yesterday and we flew
here because we never had a chance to
come to New Zealand I hope that I
actually get some time to spin beyond
this trip next time and just explore
both the north and and the South Island
but yeah thank you I appreciate that and
until then I'm going to do my best to
enjoy this moment I'm really grateful
you all decided to spend an evening with
us because it's going to be a pretty
special evening for me and for Ryan and
I think it'll be a special evening for
you all as well so Ryan and I began this
journey eight nine years ago and it took
us through a bunch of paths we've met
some really interesting people along the
way and one of those interesting people
is here tonight you might know him from
his TED Talks
you might know him as the founder of a
company called CD Baby you might know
him from his book called
anything you want you might know him
from his online musings and his
beautiful writing you might know him
from his minimalism or his
unconventional ideas on parenting you
might know him as just all-around
inspirational guy please welcome to the
stage Derek Siver's
[Music]
Jessica I'm not sure where you are but
if I could move this clock down here
because I want to be respectful of
everyone's time so wherever you are
Jessica if we could move that I'd really
appreciate it we once did an event for
five and a half hours in Atlanta because
I got lost with time and while some of
you might like that
others will be furious and I'm sure some
of you have babysitter's that you have
to pay by the hour yeah we got in
trouble for it so yeah yeah so we'll do
our best and then do you have I had some
notes Jess that I handed you know
well anyway we'll go ahead and dive in
we'll get started you know it's
interesting they're a bunch of firsts
going on tonight
this is Derek Siver's this is your first
appearance in public in what three years
I believe years yep and saying no to
everything for three years and I live in
Wellington and these guys told me they
were coming through Auckland and a few
months ago they said can you come and I
said no and I said but ask again in a
couple months and so then just two weeks
ago they said can you come I said
yeah all right sure so he actually said
no twice but now we are here and we're
grateful for that we're gonna talk about
saying no and some of the good reasons
for saying no tonight so that's a first
also you haven't done an interview in
two years now Ryan and I actually don't
do interviews we occasionally bring on
friends or new friends and we have we
have conversations with them about the
topics of minimalism and everything else
I'm not thank you Jess I trade you thank
you ma'am appreciate that so we don't do
interviews per se but we like to have
conversations about minimalism
although here's the thing minimalism is
just a Trojan horse to get us in the
door and let us talk about whatever the
hell we want to talk about and we're
also gonna answer some of your questions
tonight as well I figured we'd have a
bit of a conversation with Derek and
then we've got a mic back there
eventually be able to line up and we'll
get to as many questions as we can
here's another first for us though
I've never spoken at a racetrack before
you Ryan well not in this setting now
and so it's funny when when Derek got
here he took an uber from from the
airport he sent me a text and I believe
the text said I'm here ellipsis I think
the text II said is this where you want
to go I said I doubt it but I guess so
now as you all know as as a rule
actually some people have this weird
misconception that to be a minimalist
you have to have great hair and that's
only partially true it's actually you
have to have a great haircut and I think
for silvers he has the most appropriate
haircut and I am I am just infinitely
jealous of the haircut because I can't
pull it off I look like something from
one of the Terminator vs. alien movies
when I when I shaved my head so anyway
uh Derek and I were emailing back and
forth this is a lesson in persistence
and after the first few times he told me
no and I believe in consent and so I was
working toward yes here there are really
four words when I think of Derek Siver's
writing or even I just think of Derek
Siver's as a human being I I think of
four words and so I wrote these down and
I sent these to him simple creative
considerate and calm and I know for me
that that when when you approach your
writing it's elegant and it's like the
bones are it's beauty you have a book
out there called anything you want and I
have the physical copy and virtually the
whole thing is highlighted just because
like it's felt like you wrote that book
one tweet at a time and I think the
truth is you probably had to distill it
down to one tweet at a time
should I talk about that if you'd like
who's that a question it's a
conversation yeah I actually recently so
I've been writing for for many years but
I didn't consider myself a writer I just
kind of felt like as I go through life
if there's something that I learned you
know it's easier to give your friend
advice than to take that advice yourself
right so usually when I'm writing
something it sounds like I'm like being
bossy and telling you what to do but
it's really like I'm telling it to my
future self because I keep forgetting
these things but I realize that I do
have a writing process which was seven
steps let's see if I can remember them
all which is like first I write down
everything I have to say on a subject
and then second I argue against it and I
try to prove all those points wrong
because I usually just assume I'm full
of [ __ ] and then three is that three
three is something else and four is just
like leave it for a couple you oh three
just like I do that until I'm sick of it
right and then I'm just sick it I have
nothing more to say on the subject and
then number four I leave it for a long
time and just go away and then come back
to it when I go oh yeah I forgot about
that that was kind of a cool idea and
then but then I argue it some more and
then I look at this big giant messy pile
of thoughts it's just like so clutter
your night and I hate it and so I just
try to reduce it down to its very
essence I say okay let me just make an
outline to kind of summarize all this
giant wall of text and when I'm done I
just posted the outline instead but it
takes the giant sort of hoard of
material in order to get to that distill
down ball that that that the the seven
or the just the outline itself right it
takes almost building up this mass this
yeah for me it's not yet you need the
the huge chunk of granite from which you
can then carve out the the piece of art
so actually I'm so curious you know so
those of you listening I'm like staring
at 500 faces here and it's kind of
freaking me out I'm wondering what you
guys are doing here and I
I've actually kind of wished that you
know when we were the music was playing
if the song wasn't so good I might have
interrupted to ask you guys why you're
here and does anybody like have some
concrete reason why you came here that
you could shout out well duh like
something that you were coming here to
learn something I mean is it or is this
just like a kind of a big dating group
that you wanted to meet other
minimalists or something
can somebody shout something out there
like something you were here to learn or
and were you looking for like tips on
okay like moral support or or likes
concrete advice okay thanks
anybody else like
well yeah Derek has thrown us into the
question round already curious like I
couldn't make it I couldn't just look at
all these faces and returned I wasn't
too curious sorry
what can we repeat how do we summarize
that question for these so we have we
actually have two questions that are
connected perfectly we have one that
says hey I want to be able to get rid of
a bunch of crap right
and the other question is once I've
gotten rid of a bunch of crap what the
hell do I fill my life with and I think
that
so you're you're rich in Diaries is what
I'm hearing you say you're rich with
Diaries oh I see I see oh I am such a
dumb American I was oh my goodness
so so she's here to learn how to say no
more often is what it sounds like no
good summarize okay lady gel with Derek
severs well so here's something we were
up in the green room before this and and
you and I were exchanged emails back and
forth talking about the concept of
complexity versus simplicity okay yeah
all right
so I've thought about this subject a lot
I've been emailing with these guys for
years I've been kind of living this life
for years - and I think about it a lot
and I realize that to me of course it
goes beyond just the stuff it's like
crazy throw out some stuff and then you
say okay well now what and I realized
that to me that the bigger point it
comes down to is Society of complex
versus simple and I learned this from a
programmer recently that the word
complex we think of complicated and
complex it actually comes from the word
complex which means to braid two things
together when you complex two things you
braid them together and so when
something is complicated it means it's
intertwined or tangled with other things
and then simple comes from the word
simplex which means like one something
that's not connected to anything else is
just a single thing and I started
looking at life through this lens a bit
realizing that that was the real issue
that that interested me more than
throwing out stuff is how to make my
life less complicated like less bound to
other things and so we were geeking out
in the weeks
up until now like trading ideas about
what we were going to talk about about
the ways that we're so bound to things
sometimes mindlessly right like a lot of
my friends are creative artists and they
do things like keep all of their stuff
in Adobe Creative Cloud or in Google
Documents
but now you've bound yourself to Google
Docs and everything you create is in
Google Docs and now it's like if Google
accidentally shut down your account
tomorrow you're screwed because you are
completely dependent on Google to do
what you're doing and I've been online
since 1994 I'm kind of an old timer I'm
48 and in the first dot-com boom there
were a lot of companies that started up
that for one example I was in the music
business so mp3.com in 1999 and 2000
every single musician in the world was
on mp3.com it was like indispensable you
had to have your music there that was
the entire music business was going on
at mp3.com and then and everybody
uploaded all of their music and they
kept all of their fan lists they're like
all of their mailing lists everybody
they knew was interfaced through mp3.com
and then two years later it shut down
and everything was deleted and they were
just screwed all their music they'd ever
uploaded there are thousands of fans
just gone and then I saw them do it
again a couple years later with MySpace
and then myspace was the [ __ ] everybody
was on MySpace and you put all of your
fans there and all of your interactions
with your all of your fans were all
through MySpace and then you know it's
like it didn't actually disappear but
it's moot right so it might as well be
gone and then now it's 2018 and I see
everybody doing that with Facebook and
Instagram and all these things that they
just assume they're going to be there
forever but I think about this
comparison that like right now in 2018
we were at the the longest bull run ever
like since the 1920s in the stock market
right and so you can imagine somebody
that's only been investing for 15 years
they don't even know what it is to ever
see the stock market go down for a
single quarter right so a lot of people
today don't even know what it is to have
these companies that you think are
dependable just disappear so I often ask
my friends when I see them using like at
gmail accounts and and uploading all
their kids pictures to Facebook I say
well what would happen if your account
got deleted tomorrow like how screwed
would you be the people who what do you
mean that can't happen I need that and
it is it happened to a friend of mine in
Singapore he's a tech savvy guy - he's
like a VC tech in
during Singapore and because he's so
tech-savvy and thinking of himself as so
forward-thinking when he had a son 10
years ago he started just uploading all
of the photos of his newborn son to
Google photos was it Picasa or Google
photos maybe it's the same thing and he
did this for like nine years that was
the master copy of all of his photos of
his kid went straight to Google photos
and then he started this new company and
decided to merge his personnal at gmail
account with Google Apps and with his
you know domain and when he merged the
two suddenly his Google photos were gone
and it was like emailing customer
support like excuse me where are my
photos they said well you merged your
two accounts and so it resets your
photos he said well could you get them
back please they said well no they're
gone you deleted them when he emerged
accounts he said but those are all of my
photos of my kid and his wife is like
what have you done it's gone I don't
like [ __ ] it's a company they'd like
you pay that's like you don't depend on
a company anyway so I think about a lot
of this subject of like you don't
complex your life together with things
stop depending on your social media
accounts don't if you're depending on
Gmail for your email they you know they
might shut down your account someday for
no reason cuz that somebody was trying
to run a scam through it and then your
gmail account is gone and so I'm kind of
preaching this thing that the to me is
about simplifying your life by reducing
your dependencies like that when we were
talking about that upstairs and you were
talking about this intertwining like
instantly I thought about marriage like
I was thinking about that the analogy of
how when when you pick out a partner
hope it'll be careful yeah hopefully all
of us who are going to get married
hopefully we have picked out that
partner very deliberately and what what
it's so easy to do now a day nowadays is
to get to get married to Facebook to get
married to Twitter to get married to in
certain to get married to Gmail and we
do it without really thinking about why
we're we're
marrying ourselves to to these different
tools that we have available yeah it's
it's to me it's it's also kind of that
super long term view that a lot of my
friends are musicians and they're in
their 20s and 30s and I think you're
going to be making music longer than
Facebook is in business like Facebook
will probably go out of business in the
next 50 years while you're still making
music so don't depend on that as your
source of you know where you do
everything right anyway
yeah well it's like a service like
Google you know your friend is uploading
those photos that is a free service so
he when they're all deleted leg really
there's kind of looking at I'm like what
you expect ride they're doing you a
favor our bed now they don't really
think that the binding concept applies
to possessions as well quite often we'll
continue to hold on to things in
perpetuity just because we acquired them
itself and that's the path that you guys
found that you know you you talked about
that
a lot of people have to find this out
the hard way what was the code word for
it like every now that you know
everybody sometimes a single sentence
can change your mind right like you can
hear people talk and talk and talk and
then a certain sentence will hit you and
for me it's when I heard somebody say
something like you don't wanna you don't
have to be the steward of your
possessions through it's one of those
kind of words like like a museum curator
or something like that it was this idea
of somebody who kind of keeps the dust
off the item forever like you don't want
to be the steward of your items like oh
yeah
you started in you think of every little
thing you buy is like oh wait that's
this is gonna sit here forever and till
I get rid of it and the little did you
guys see the video called the story of
stuff that one like made a huge impact
on me too if you guys haven't seen the
story of stuff like when you said like
you need the extra tips or help on not
buying stuff or getting rid of stuff the
story of stuff might change your life
because this woman made an animated
video showing you all of the waste
that's created in every single thing
what do you think like I'll just get
some shoes you know they're like 12
bucks at the warehouse 12 bucks why not
but then it's like you find out like how
much waste goes into creating that
stupid pair of shoes and sudden you look
at it with a new new eyes and yeah that
video made a huge difference for me
when we were talking about surrounding
ourselves with the with objects the
objects that they're closest to us
actually in our documentary we we
interviewed a gal named Juliet Shore and
the thing that she said is the problem
isn't there were two materialist so
we're not materialist enough and in fact
there are some things that really
augment our experience of life that
improve our life and choosing those
things wisely is is important but
instead what we've done is just tried to
amass more of whatever right and I also
think about the this we that's right we
talked about the idea of introducing
friction okay so now I mention this I
moved to New Zealand six years ago and
in America you get addicted to Amazon
it's just so damn easy to like anything
in the world you just do and it just
shows up at your door the next day and
it's basically wholesale price and then
I moved to New Zealand and there is no
Amazon here and what I found is that
like my initial impulse would happen I'd
like I need some new headphones I'll get
some new headphones like oh [ __ ] they
cost how much here and I'm just like I
never I don't need headphones and I just
I stopped being a consumer cuz it's just
like there was just enough friction now
that I was like no never mind
I just don't buy stuff as much now
because there's no Amazon so then we
talked about if there's something in
your life that is maybe too easy like
you know Facebook or Instagram on your
phone is just a little too easy to like
suck you in introducing this friction so
what I started doing years ago is I used
a random string generator on my computer
to generate this 32 character long
password and I changed my facebook
password to that but it's only on my
computer so it's saved and like a GPG
encrypted thing on my computer is my
Facebook password and I didn't have the
app on my phone anyway but I did the
same thing with my email so now on my
phone I can't check my facebook or email
I don't even know what my password is I
can only do it back at my computer so
even it's like in those those times of
what do you call that like low willpower
for the same reason I deleted my ex-girl
phone number from my phone it's like so
you know it's like you don't want to be
in that position at like 1:00 in the
morning going wait hold on I'm not so
strong right now so you you introduce
some friction in between you and the
things you don't want in your life I
think sometimes that friction also gives
you traction in ways it because if you
have if everything is absolute
convenience all the time and it's Amazon
at my door whenever I want it in LA its
same-day delivery now and so you have
all these in then you can get the food
delivered to you there's no reason to
ever leave right and so like I'm this at
home laying on the couch having someone
feed carbohydrates to me all day at some
point there's there's no meaning purpose
joy in that you often mistake these
little moments of pleasure the ephemeral
fleeting pleasures as though that's real
purpose or joy in our lives but
obviously it's not we realized that
whenever we pan out but when we remove
some of those overindulgent conveniences
intentionally not not depriving
ourselves but intentionally said I'm not
going to do that it removing that the
adding the friction creates some
traction in our lives so that we are
when we are in those sort of
interstitial zones at a doctor's office
you're waiting in line to order food or
you're the grocery store the checkout
line
you're not just sort of passively lost
in the glowing screen like a zombie it
okay I'm gonna say something else I
shouldn't say so how many most of you
here from New Zealand okay so I've been
here for so long that the American
accent kind of sounds strange to me a
bit and so when these guys came on stage
before the podcast started you know and
they were talking I was kind of sitting
in the back going how do we sound like
that and I was thinking of you know hunt
for the wildered
Tyco is like the preacher he's just like
yeah and behind that first door remember
what's we you know behind the second
door is like this earnestness of the
preacher and and I was thinking how
it sounds to religion when people are
saying like you know and then I was at
Milo and my buddy came to me and he said
minimalism it will show you the way and
it's just like you could almost put any
word in there right
Scientology my friend why am I so happy
Scientology why am I so happy
sex sex my friend it's the best yeah I'm
really glad that I stumbled across
minimalism it not Scientology and it in
that moment of searching because I think
I probably I was really susceptible to
to like okay I'm looking for some new
ideas because this current idea isn't
working thankfully I found one that
doesn't have a Dogma to it though so
nice transition I wanted to talk about
dogma look at that expert MC on the mic
hey we're not supposed to say when there
is a transition it's supposed to be a
natural segue music okay so Dogma I was
okay I don't
I didn't bring my dictionary with things
but I think that the difference between
dogmatic and pragmatic is when you're
being dogmatic you want to take
something and act like it's the answer
to everything right like I have found
minimalism it is the answer to
everything
and then pragmatics is you're using it
as a tool where it's needed in your life
right so I have a five year olds now six
year old kid and these guys asked me
about parenting and how minimalism
applies to parenting and I thought about
it for a second I thought okay here's
how it applies is I learned that it
doesn't apply and at first I was
dogmatic about it right when my kid was
two years old I was just like oh no toys
we're going outside and playing with
pinecones and I'd like I live like right
down like breaker Bay by the airport in
Wellington or there's all these rocks
out there and I would just take him out
to the rocks and like no you don't need
toys we got rocks come on
by the way do you member fly to the
Conchords New Zealand rocks the joke and
flight of the conchords is all the tours
and posters never have a person in them
New Zealand is always advertised as this
place with no people like you know New
Zealand Iraq Sandia okay so um so would
always just take my kid out to play with
you know limpets and and sticks and
pinecones
and then one day I took him to a
restaurant in Lama Rapa that had a huge
giant box of toys and he was just like
and I finished eating in 20 minutes and
he sat there for three hours with these
toys just like playing with his captain
he was so into it he was riveted and I
just sat there for three hours watching
just like I suck man this I shouldn't
have pushed my [ __ ] [ __ ] on him you
know so I was like okay I'm being
dogmatic about this like my kid doesn't
need minimalism he's - so that was an
important distinction for me it's
realizing like okay this is this is a
tool so best thing ever by the way what
they don't have in America is trade me
and so I went to trade me and for 25
bucks I found somebody in Wellington who
was moving to Australia and like took
all of their kids toys and a huge crate
and I bought it for 25 bucks and still
like four or five years later now my kid
plays with that same box of toys for 25
bucks all the time it's like his main
you know if there's like 300 toys in
there like action figures and dinosaurs
and boats and cars and and aliens and he
brings them into the bath and it's like
the best damn 25 bucks but yeah I
realized that it's we got to use this as
a as a tool as a pragmatic tool not a
dogmatic thing to apply to everything
yeah I think this is a great example of
how like Josh and I we do not we do not
recommend deprivation I mean deprivation
is not fun and just like Josh said like
any of y'all could run a dumpster and
throw everything away when you get home
and you're just gonna probably have a
big chance of being miserable in an
empty place but what I do think is that
when when we do I know for me like when
I did that that stoical experiment of
packing all my stuff up but kind of
going through it for me
that's well first off as a single dude
living by himself that's a very very
easy thing to do but for like a family
of six likely Oba bout to probably
wouldn't do that that doesn't really
make a lot of sense for a big family but
for me having having taken everything
out and and really getting down to that
the essence it kind of helped me realize
like what I needed to bring back in so I
think the the the experiment that you
did with your child like I don't yeah
you were depriving them but as a good
parent you were like oh I am NOT being a
good parent right now and I want to be a
good parent and I'm not gonna deprive my
kid anymore and and yet dude I'm sorry
but you're still minimalist your kids
still minimalist but that toy that box
of toys man it that was a very
deliberate thing you brought it and it
sounds like those toys add a lot of
value to his life yeah then what two
boxes make him happier no yeah we talked
about this like so does that mean that
yeah 10 boxes would be better yeah
you're right it's like I guess we all
just find the balance but there's 10
times more joy and I think that's the
problem with toys and so the stat that
from the UK is the average child in the
UK has 300 toys but plays with 12 daily
however the argument would be if they're
playing with 300 toys regularly then
what's what's the real problem here
right the problem for us is we have our
own toys as adults right it just it just
turns into something else it becomes you
know we live in Los Angeles now I've
never seen more Ferraris in my life and
I'm like in the backseat of Ryan's
Toyota Corolla of watching driving past
each one and and realizing that that we
do the same thing we try to amass more
not because it's necessarily better but
there are cases we're having the things
in our life one of the things we were
talking about earlier is like yeah you
want to have the things that will aid
the experience of life most a good bed a
good pair of shoes the things you keep
closest to you haven't talked about the
different definitions so for a little
while I got sucked into these circles of
digital No
right like Colin you know by the way
Colin Wright lived in Christchurch for
six months like right before the
earthquake that was one of his spots and
so I got sucked into these circles of
digital nomads and at one point they
asked me to speak at a digital nomad
conference in Berlin and it was like
this is like 500 people all who called
themselves digital nomads it was a
little creepy and what was funny though
is realizing how different their
definitions were so a lot of people I
heard a lot of people talk about this
idea of travelling for a while like they
would go to live somewhere cheap in Bali
or Thailand and then they'd go back home
to live at home whether that was Chicago
or or London or whatever and then they'd
go out and they'd live somewhere cheap
again and then come home and I realized
we had a different definition because to
me Nomad means like you keep going like
there there's no more home anymore you
keep going constantly that was my
personal definition then I realized my
definition is different than most
people's and so minimalism came up when
my friend came to visit New Zealand and
he stayed at my apartment and I pulled
out my laptop which is this huge giant
bulky nine year old Lenovo laptop and
he's like dude what are you doing with
that old laptop I was like it works and
in his version of minimalism is like
every year he finds the the smaller
better faster computers who he can be
minimalist which to him means light and
portable everything fits into a tiny
backpack and so he'll buy lots and lots
of stuff to find the tiniest stuff it's
just I was surprised it was a different
definition whereas my definition was
like if you have something that works
you don't need to keep buying stuff so I
have this giant old ancient laptop still
and just it's funny to realize that we
have different definitions of the same
word which if you don't mind me taking
one more fun tangent on that yes oh [ __ ]
we insist
oh okay so so it reminded me of this
idea of you have a cocktail party you
have two doctors and two lawyers and so
you introduce the two doctors thinking
like you guys are both doctors you
should talk and you introduce the two
lawyers thinking that they have
something in common but then you find
out that one of the doctors got into it
because his mother died of this disease
and he's decided
that he never wants anybody to ever die
of this disease again the second doctor
got into it for the prestige and one
lawyer got into it because his dad was
wrongly imprisoned for years and he's
decided to right those wrongs and the
other lawyer got into it for the
prestige so the what doesn't matter as
much as the why so actually that lawyer
and that doctor have more in common and
this so I think about you know here we
are with five hundred people that came
to this talk by the minimalists I'll bet
you there are a lot of different wise in
this room it's like this is just the
what but the why makes a huge difference
I think I think getting to that why is
one of the most important things during
the talk earlier and the question that I
started with the starters whole journey
was how might your life be better with
less it was a question from Josh Rebecca
and I realize like for me it was one
thing at first and that often leads to
other wise as well so for me I was like
I need to regain control of my finance
that's six figures worth of debt I made
really good money but I spent even
better money and that equation just
doesn't work and so I had massive
amounts of debt half a million dollars
if you count my mortgage and so that was
my initial Y but then it was like you'd
start uncovering as as I simplified it
was like oh I weighed 80 pounds more
than I weigh now and so it was regaining
control of my health
it was regaining control of my time it
was working 70 or 80 hours a week and it
supposedly successful career that sure
[ __ ] didn't feel successful because I
didn't even have controlled my own time
everyone else got to dictate how I live
my life it was a special kind of sort of
enslavement in a way and so and in a way
I was a slave to a lifestyle a template
that someone else had had sold men so
I've got a bunch of stuff to show for
sort of the trophies of success but I
wasn't it was no longer my idea of
success yeah it's it's crazy when I when
I first found minimalism Josh the first
thing he sent me was a video that Colin
write did on Facebook and you know when
I when I mentioned him in my story about
him being you know 24-year old
entrepreneur you know traveled with
everything on his back I mean he
literally was like known for having 52
things and I remember seeing this and my
first thought was is I don't want to be
a minimalist
because I like having a kitchen table I
like having game nights I like having a
couch or maybe two couches like so I
could you know have teams of what we
would play cranium and and other stuff
and III then saw people like Joshua
Becker like Cortney Carver like leo bob
alta and it was really inspiring to see
to see people using this thing called
minimalism to say no and for me I had to
say I had to say no more in my life and
what it was it was it was these people
setting the example and by default
giving me permission to relive my art to
rework my life to really try and rework
what I was I was focusing on honestly
man it just looked like common sense but
unfortunately common sense it ain't too
common especially where I come from I
think at the beginning of the
documentary where are you skateboarding
where is that Missoula Montana
yeah thanks there is a lot of common
sense in Missoula
that's why I move there so right on that
point you know I think both of us in our
20s we we got to the top of that ladder
because we kept saying yes to everything
you're smelling a transition here are
you sure it's not me sweating Ryan you
smell like transition so so I think we
said yes to a whole lot of things and
it's the individually a lot of things
that we said yes to through our 20s they
all sounded like grand opportunities on
their own but when you stack them all
together then you start actually
accidentally saying no to what's
important just by excluding them and I
think to take back control of my life I
had to start I had to learn I had to
practice saying no and I can tell you
Derek one of the things that you wrote
about that is one of the things that
that fully articulated what I was trying
to do and in saying and in saying no
more frequently so I could say yes to
what was important can you talk about
that
yo Derek drop the purse okay so yeah
it's funny in 2009 I wrote I was trying
to make a decision whether I should go
to this conference or not and just like
yeah I probably should maybe and and I
thought you know what I'm sick of always
trying to decide between yes and no I
thought from now on I'm gonna make it so
if I'm feeling anything less than oh
hell yeah then I'll just say no so I'm
gonna say no to everything less than
hell yeah so am I feeling like hell yeah
about going to that conference no am I
feeling like hell yeah about doing this
job somebody asked me to do it's like
okay and I just started saying no to all
of it because the big idea was that that
if you say no to almost everything then
you have like free time and you have
like space in your life and then the big
strategy is then when that rare
occasional thing comes along like some
kind of gig I mean I'm freelance you
know so when the occasional gig comes
along that you're just like oh hell yeah
now that I'm psyched about well then
suddenly you've got all these free time
and you can throw yourself into that
thing completely so to me this just
seemed to be a better life strategy so I
wrote it up in just a tiny itty-bitty
little article like four paragraphs in
2009 and it's become like my my hit
single like people quoted then friends
in Silicon Valley tell me that like
people say hell yeah or no in meetings
all the time and they're just like and I
think it was on Shark Tank or something
like that but yeah that's the big idea
is just this idea of instead of instead
of trying to decide between yes or no
yeah if you're feeling anything less
than hell yeah and say no and it just
leaves this great space in your life
so let me how do you get over cuz I mean
I know how I get over it but I'm just
curious how you get over it like you say
so someone asks you hey Derek can you do
X and you're like no sorry I can't
how do you get over them being like
offended or that's a great question it
I too lie until I got to New Zealand and
just you know I was living in Singapore
before this since and different cultures
have different ways of doing things and
you know the Asian culture is not always
about being blunt and direct it's often
about being indirect in saving face and
being polite so when I was living in
Singapore I would turn things down with
polite lies like oh just busy that day
you can't do it that day well how about
for the next day busy that day too
maybe the next week yeah maybe maybe
let's listen you know and then I got and
I moved to New Zealand I'm just like I
don't want to do that anymore this isn't
the kind of place for that and so I
shouldn't admit this but when I first
moved to New Zealand I moved to Nelson
deliberately because I didn't know
anybody there and I thought like nobody
will ask me to do anything if I live in
Nelson so but then my ex she grew up in
New York City and she couldn't handle
the small town Nelson life so she
insisted we moved to Wellington so I
kind of crumbled my way into Wellington
but I knew like 150 people in Wellington
and so when people in Wellington would
ask me to do something I was like it was
tempting to do that old habit of lying
and instead I just would say like no I'm
really just working on some stuff and
I'm I'm really just enjoying getting
lost in my work and I'm sorry I don't
really want to interrupt my flow to meet
up and it's hard to say sometimes
because sometimes it's like friends that
live like three blocks away and I'm like
sorry man they're like I haven't seen
you in nine months like I know sorry I
just I'm already into my thing and I'm
digging it and here's what happens
unless they're lying back to me every
single one is just said you know what
that's really cool man I know how that
goes stick with the flow go for it you
know and people get it cuz I think a lot
of people wish that they said no more
often and so when you say no to them you
become like a role model and how to say
no so that's why you got to tell the
truth you know when Derek said no to
this interview in the first the first
time we're all so persistent actually
josh is more persistent but what I'll
say is when he said no he said you know
yeah I'm really trying to be a good
father not good but he said I'm busy
this summer being a dad and
now Josh and I would have been like we
can't believe that Eric Severus told us
no what would that is said about us
really more than anything and but you
know hearing the way that he said no
like who here would knock anyone not
just Derek Siver's but any of your
friends who here would knock them for
giving an excuse like that I would love
to give me some of my time but I really
need to give my kids time summer
holidays yeah IIIi really thought it was
a commendable response because yeah I
have a four year old and it's one of the
things I struggle with and especially
because I'm an introvert like you I like
I'm an extreme introvert I know it's
weird because I'm in front of 500 people
right now but I do spend 90% of my time
alone and I've set my life up that way
so I could do it back in my corporate
days I spent virtually a hundred percent
of my time around other people and it
ruined my life and and I've set my life
up in a way that I have people around me
who also understand that when I say no
it's so I can say yes to me and I also I
can be a better version of myself when
I'm there I'm sure that when you do
spend the time with the person three
blocks away you've been dodging for nine
months that time that you do spend
together is higher-quality time because
you're you're getting out of it the
other time what you need so you can be
the best version of yourself when you
show up you know one of the questions
when we were trading ideas before now
about what we might talk about on stage
one of the ideas you mentioned was about
being less stressed or being calm or
less stressed and you asked why or how
and I thought about it for a bit and I
realized that it's it's about being
sincere I think that your your most
stressed when you're being insincere
when you're doing stuff that you don't
really want to do or maybe even you know
yeah saying saying yes to stuff that you
wish you didn't say yes to were just
living the life that doesn't really feel
like it's really for you it kind of
gives you this internal friction and
when you suddenly just kind of commit to
just like saying [ __ ] it and just being
honest with people it's just like yeah
life is easier in calmer
well so so when I think of Derek I think
of aggressively calm even his voice you
hear his voice in your lie like this is
that I just like feel all of a sudden
like 10 decibels calmer and and and and
so I assume that there are maybe it's
just the because you are now sincere
your your short term actions are
congruent with the person that you want
to be yeah I
what did a stressed-out Derek Siver's
look like though it's just more internal
conflict it's just the outside might
have seen the same but I think I was
like I said it was just like lying more
often and it just it comes to realizing
your priorities too so it's like I was
very split yeah I was very split between
lots of different responsibilities and
things I had said yes to and then my kid
was born in Singapore and I've moved
here to New Zealand with this idea of
actually know what the inspiration was I
was a musician and I remember reading as
a teenager that John Lennon regretted
the fact that went like during the
height of Beatlemania his first son
Julian was born and he had like no time
to spend with Julian at all so he just
completely missed Julian's slide from
the song Hey Jude is about Julia Anna
and then he was 35 when when he was with
Yoko and Sean Lennon was born and he
just said like okay right he just told
his agent and manager like no for the
next five years no to everything and so
for the first five years of his kid's
life he just disappeared from the world
for five years and even John Lennon did
it I was like yeah if he can do it I can
do it
so yeah that's you know I moved to New
Zealand to move to Nelson at first and
just said no to the whole world is like
I'm just gonna hang out with my kid for
five years and no to everything else so
and you've let him experience the world
in a way that I still struggle with so
so maybe you can help me and then by
proxy help some other people in here any
parents in here tonight that's -
apparently that's two hands went up
that's great
bunch of [ __ ] minimalists
yeah liova baltha has six kids that's
what I knew I could be a minute what if
a guy with six kids he's Superman he
doesn't even believe in condoms you know
you're talking about like the three most
dangerous words was that part of your
talk uh yeah just in case I was thinking
there's that there's a lot of dangerous
three word combinations but he said that
I was like sitting in the back and I was
just thinking just like your religion
sucks is is it in things like that there
are a lot of fun dangerous three word
combinations
well back to parenting there's some so
you've written exactly one time if you
go to Silverstone org slash pas PA
you've written one time about about
parenting and there were some some
concepts in there that you talked about
embracing a longer attention span
because with me I got I think a lot of
the beach in 20 minutes in I'm like are
you ready to go yet sand all over my
damn shoes and and I'm just and for you
you're like and then we'll go play in
the park for 17 hours straight and I
just need some help man it's that I
don't know that's that's I don't know I
try to think of like funny entertaining
answers but sorry this is just really
boring but it it's just that to me when
I think about what what I value in life
like what do i what do I value and what
traits do I want my kid to have to me a
long attention span is one of the best
things that anybody can have and
especially I see it as being
counter-trend you know road less
traveled and all that like whatever the
opposite of everybody else is doing is
what's more valuable and so just early
on I was just like this is a top
priority for me I want my kid to have a
long attention span and so ever since he
was a little baby we were just like go
out to the park and it's almost like one
of those movies have you ever seen those
it's just like a cheap filmmaker trick
where one person sits still and then
they fast motion everybody else and so
you see like a blur of people going in
well one person sits
that's like me and my kid on the
playground we would just like go to some
random little playground and Nelson and
just sit there for like five hours just
poking around and everybody else would
come and go for 20 minutes at a time and
he just sit there for like five hours
and I just I mean I'm thankful that my
life was such that I could do that
you know because to me the the biggest
friction I see in parents who say that
parenting is hard is when they're trying
to fit their kids into an adult schedule
it's all this kind of like come on we
got to go now I told you get ready come
on gotta go it's 20 minutes we need to
leave and that's to me the biggest
friction is tryin but it's like if you
let I always just let my kid lead the
way and he's he's the boss and I just
love getting into his pace and his world
and sorry it sounds corny but it's a
little bit like meditation for me when
because I just shut it shut me off right
my stuff's done my computers off I don't
bring my phone with me when I hang out
with him I miss out on some photos but
it helps with the focus you know so my
phone is gone and it's just me and him
and I just love being at his pace and
it's like myself disappears and I just
enter his mind and whatever he says goes
if he says suddenly just like oh yeah
dad you need to hide the aliens are
coming I'm like oh my god they're coming
and so you know with whatever reality he
creates is for both of us and and I just
enter his world and I just it's like
meditation in the way that I don't
really meditate but friends of mine that
do they say that if if they don't they
feel out of sorts and I feel the same
way like if he and I haven't hung out at
his pace like this I feel out of sorts
because I haven't entered his world in a
long time you know you also you also
talked about broad inputs and exposing
him to whether it's not just going to
the park or the beach but the New
Zealand Symphony Orchestra and and I
found that fascinating too because when
you talk about entering his world
you're also it's as much for you as it
is for him right away yeah definitely so
this
stuff I'm talking about right now it's
as you can tell it's like I'm I'm saying
I'm doing it for him and I am but I've
noticed in the meantime that it makes me
super blissed-out to to just enter his
world but then yeah whenever he's at
home playing with Lego I'm putting on
like freaky music I'm putting on Bartok
string quartets and Indian classical
music and I'm trying to like expand his
his range of what he considers to be
normal music you know I mean I went to
Berklee School of Music I'm a musician
so I kind of have always been into a
bunch of weird music so it's really fun
to just put that onto the background as
he's making Legos he's listening to the
Bulgarian women's choir screaming you
know and it's just normal to him and so
actually he calls it Lego music in
Indian classical music he calls it Lego
music so yeah and then purposely taking
him to new places I have to you know it
expands my horizons too and yeah it's
wonderful yeah well that's the thing
I've noticed and being a parent is it's
one of the most difficult things I've
ever done although apparently I'm doing
it wrong and but it also is like the
most sort of growth inducing like
positive growth and and so I'm learning
a bunch and hopefully we can get to some
questions here because I want to be
really respectful of your time but we
can try to squeeze in some questions so
your microphone areas there so there's a
microphone somewhere back here I've been
told
unless someone but you can shout too and
we can repeat you okay it's right here
go ahead and line up it at that mic and
they will or questions hopefully we get
a question or two about
about business or creating as well
because I'd love to talk to Derek about
that we could sit here all night and
talk but we're here for you go ahead man
what's your name where you from
hey Keota welcome to New Zealand Derek
welcome to Oakland my name is Ryan
awesome name it
yeah thanks yeah hey I had a question
it's actually pretty topical my wife and
I just had a baby
he's like eight weeks old
it's thank you Congrats man that's
awesome
it's pretty hard Derrick's I don't know
what you're talking about
but anyway how do you say no when people
just want to give you a load of [ __ ]
like I'm talking like they give you bags
and bags of clothes like ear Jordans for
babies and my son can't even walk
yeah but ya know without like looking
like a jerk trade me honestly like I
think because some day some people it
makes them feel nice to give you the
stuff and sometimes you're actually kind
of doing them a favor sometimes you're
helping them get rid of their junk which
you know it's like the bigger picture
it's like you take on the burden of
yourself for a minute but I mean I don't
trade me it's just so useful man it's I
found this great strategy
you could put anything on there for a
dollar and the price always goes up I
actually I had a grand piano that I cuz
I moved from a house in Nelson to a
little apartment in Wellington and so I
tried selling my grand piano on trade me
and I listed it at like $15,000 and like
nobody bid and I was like 14,000 nobody
bid and this went on for two months and
finally just to see what would happen I
put it on sale for a dollar and then
people followed it and bid it all the
way back up to two fifteen thousand or
whatever but so I found this like great
thing I'm trading me that if you just
list everything there for a dollar
somebody always wants that stuff there's
some people who need it and then you can
give it away so I know it's awkward when
people dump their stuff on you but yeah
yeah you can you can keep read umping so
so happy I agree because the thing
doesn't add value to your life doesn't
mean it won't add value to someone
else's life so being willing to let go
is actually more responsible than just
shoving it in a storage locker for six
years and then paying on that storage
locker
month after month after month after
month but so for those of you listening
at home trade me is uh the New Zealand
of eBay and Amazon sort of together but
the other thing that I'll say is over
time and this won't happen this won't
happen overnight but over time it has
more to do with setting the expectation
so instead of saying no no no no I don't
want this stuff so what do you want what
are you gonna say yes to right maybe
it's gifting experience maybe it's
gifting consumables you know someone
drops off a case of diapers that's
something you're actually going to need
and if they want to feel really good
about giving it to you they can gift
wrap and put a giant bow on it you're
gonna be much more excited to get that
then you are the the pair of eight month
old air Air Jordan yeah that's
unbelievable
the American Dream really has permeated
your borders yeah thanks for question
brother thanks man
yeah I will add one thing is that I
totally agree with your approach I I
would encourage you to at least try and
set the expectations with your friends
and family who are doing that because I
don't know which I don't know if this
has happened to you but I've done that
before where someone shows up to my
house was like hey was that thing I gave
you yeah so have you had that happen I'm
curious one time a conference I spoke at
a conference in Kuala Lumpur Malaysia
and they gave me like an awful framed
drawing of me and it was like oh thanks
do I really look like this so it was
horrible and so what I did like it was
so I I went and I found a garbage can
like behind the front desk and I put it
in there and a week later there's like
Derek we found your cone oh it was it
was in the garbage we're mailing it back
to you it was like and they mailed it to
me and said I made sure so you should
yeah back to you know talk about it
being sincere being honest instead of
being insincere there's all this
friction whenever you lie and just be
honest it yeah if you do set that
expectation then like you could feel
very good about you know going and
getting rid of that stuff because at
that point I mean like what my
grandmother like I have set the
expectation with her but you know she
last time I was at her place she tried
to give me a paperweight like you're a
writer you need a paperweight and like I
don't know how to explain the cloud to
my 84 year old grandmother
every time I go there at the reprogram
my phone number into her phone I don't
know how she keeps deleting it so I just
simply look at that paperwork I'm like
she knows that she knows I'm a
minimalist that's that that's okay um
you know I think this is beautiful
paperweight thank you so much this is
gorgeous
man I you know I if I don't end up
finding a use for this deep would you
mind if I found someone else who maybe
could use this and she's like oh do you
think you could do that that would be
great yeah find someone else who would
love it so and that's because I have set
the expectation upfront with her of yeah
how I want to bring things into my life
so she respects it when I am sincere
with her and now I have a paperweight oh
okay what's your name yeah evening I'm
Matthew pitch I'm from Middlesboro in
the UK well thank you for being here
right yeah Cheers hey look it's pretty
topical as well
Ryan kind of killed my question it was
something I had the back of my mind but
I'll rephrase it I'm a new dad and one
I'm finding particularly difficult is
staying present when I know I've got
other things going on being creative so
I was just wondering what like tips and
guidance that you potentially use to try
and declutter to make sure that you
maximize that time with the little I can
give you a practical tip but I'm
interested here here with Derek has to
say because he is a creative person
there Derek is actually rewrite in a
book about marketing for creatives he's
a musician and and so it's particularly
about marketing for its its marketing
via the lens of a musician but I think
it's for anyone who is creative and it's
it's you can find a chapter by chapter
on on his website but so as a creative
person I I get up before Ella wakes up
and that's when I write about get up
before my partner I get up before Ella
and I spend time creating I make the
time and it's fascinating
we often pretend we don't have the time
but it's the only resource we all have
the same
we today we all had 24 hours right
except when we flew here we lost a few
hours so you actually had more time than
made it there I guess is my answer
Derrick how do you balance the the
creative side that the creating but also
the the parenting is it a daily thing a
monthly thing okay I sound really
zen-like I've got it all figured out
right but but actually so many times
when I'm like leaving to go to 45 to go
get him from school at 3 o'clock I'm
sitting I was so in the middle of
something I certainly don't want this
right now ah like I'm working as fast as
I can I think I gotta get him now I got
to leave and then I think it just comes
down to the meditation 101 where they
talk about it's like yeah you have those
thoughts in your head and you just you
let them flow out and they just they
just go back out and you just let them
let them go and then creatively you just
have to trust the process that next time
you're you're back at your work that
those things will have been staying in
your unconscious you know so it's it's
not all Zen and easy I'm cursing it a
lot but then it's like once I'm actually
in person with him and he's just like
look what I made you
it just melts away and I'm like alright
I give up I'm here I'm present you know
Josh like everyone smile he'll be like
man Ryan like you do a really good job
of living in the moment and I don't even
I didn't even realize that I lived in
the moment a lot of the time and it
wasn't until like a few weeks ago that I
will forget what I was doing but I
remember I started with whatever I was
doing let's say I'm just sitting in my
computer I'm doing email and then like
you know there's a window right there
and someone passes by and I'm like
what's going on up there oh my got to go
back to my email back to my email back
to my email back to my emo and then like
I'll write a sentence I'm like man
that's a good sentence man that really
is good and that'll spark another
thought and I start to get excited and
that's the worst is when I get excited
while I'm doing something else an
excitement can be elation but I think it
can also be distraction or stress but as
soon as I started to get excitement I
will catch myself
and I will say Ryan that's it is a good
thought you can get excited about that
after you write this email and I have to
continuously avoid excitement in order
to stay in the moment there's only one
thing I can get excited about while I'm
there and it's what's in front of me
that's what I will allow myself to get
excited about and if I can't get excited
about that I'm not gonna get I'm not
gonna allow myself to get excited about
or distracted by anything else until
this one task is done and what will
eventually happen one or two things
happen I get this task done who I can go
get excited about something else or I
will actually start to get excited about
what I'm focused on and I think we were
having this conversation this morning we
were a friend DK wherever he is hey DK
and we were talking about the the
distractions are actually what keep us
from from the focus and and often I
think the excitement or worry can be can
be the same thing they can both be
equally distracting if we really want to
to be really recall focus or meditative
or being in the moment I think we have
to lose ourselves in whatever the
activity is right and so if that is just
the creative work if you're writing or
if you're making music or whatever maybe
it's losing yourself in that that that's
often we feel most alive it's it's a
different type of excitement it's like
we needed we need a different word to
really describe it you can call flow
state may be your focus and you can you
you can obviously get that with whatever
you're doing whether it's writing or sex
or you're spending time with your child
there will be difficult times to do that
to to really pour yourself into the
activity but that's that's where the
real payoff comes in howdy what's your
name hi I'm Jane by the way I think
we're gonna we'll skip the lightning
round
just so that we can dive deep into at
least two more questions so we're not
trying to give you extra pit the answers
today if that's okay with y'all hey I'm
Jane welcome to New Zealand I watch a
documentary it was really cool and I
read your book thank you um my question
is
once you start on going down that track
how do you stay on it because I've
already tried it and I've fallen off the
bandwagon and it's just making sure not
to get that crap back in your life that
you don't need so for me that is my
question is like once you start down the
minimalist track how do you ensure that
things like like I don't fast fashion
and all that sort of stuff doesn't sort
of creep back in especially you know as
a woman that's something that does
happen you know you see clothes and you
want to buy them how to use it of yeah
work around that kind of stuff so what
do you struggle with is it mainly
clothes or is it I'm just clothes and
books okay
clothes and books so so the average book
no one makes it past the first chapter
so so so 10 10% of books that are
purchased the reader makes it past the
first chapter books become a status
symbol to many of us that they also make
us feel like we've achieved some sort of
goal instead of actually experiencing
that the the yeah we've got books out
there in the lobby but you won't do you
any good sitting on your shelf right if
you read it we encourage you to pass it
on to someone else and who can get value
from it right and so I think it's it's
true the the possessions that we have
should augment our experience or they
should create an experience right and so
if you're buying the book it's
aspirational in a way but if all you're
doing is aspiring then then you know
you'll end up with aspiration everywhere
that's a pithy answer we could put that
on the lightning round
but but I don't know that you'll you'll
actually end up getting any value from
it I think the same is true with with
clothes I think quite often actually one
of the reasons there you agreed to do
this sit-down with us is I sent this
avert this advertisement essay to you
that I had finished up last month and
you and I have a really similar view on
advertisements in in the States we see
5000 advertisements a day and I'm gonna
go on a bit of a tangent but I'll circle
back I promise we see 5000
advertisements a day whether that's TV
print radio billboards
and those advertisements are backed by
statisticians and demographers and
psychologists and really well-paid
writers to aggregate your eyeballs onto
their product make it compelling enough
so they can divorce you from the money
in your checking account and so they
want it to be as compelling as possible
so that they've removed the friction
enough friction so that you will what
will purchase their item there is a drug
company in the United States who was
trying to come up with and this is a
good call so to help people who have
hypertension
and so they they did this pill trial and
they realized that this pill wasn't
working at all but the men who were
taking was they were getting astray
strange side-effect all of them were
leaving there with boners and so they
didn't just say well that's a weird
side-effect let's get rid of this they
said hey we have a solution to a problem
and so they hired an ad agency and the
drug viagra was created and that's what
we're doing with our advertisements
every single day it's the reason that we
refuse to put advertisements on our
podcast because advertisements you're
damn right they suck and so one of the
things that really stood out to me in
Derek's book anything you want was the
reason you don't put what's the reason
you don't put ads on your websites or
you didn't you refused ads on CD Baby
for many years at the kinda great
analogy for this I said it would be like
putting a Coke machine in a monastery
it's like to me my my website was like
my baby like this is my business this is
my my thing it was precious to me it was
kind of art and the idea of like putting
an ad on it just felt sacrilegious or
something like that my job revolves
around advertising so I got well so so
you know what goes really
I'm not actually in advertising but my
IT company supports it and here's the
thing I think that that they've gotten
really good at making us take money that
we don't have to buy things that we
don't need to impress people we don't
even know and so when you think about it
that way when you're about to buy that
new book or the new piece of clothes or
whatever it is maybe ask yourself why am
i buying this and who is it really for
yeah for what it's worth I found one
little hack with books whenever there's
a book I'm just like ooh I need that now
I go into Amazon and I put it in a
future wishlist and and I think yeah as
soon as I'm ready to the day I'm
actually ready to read that like I'm
ready to sit down and read that then
I'll get it right now my wishlist on
Amazon is like over 400 books and I
haven't bought any of them and I'm just
like wow that's like how many years of
thinking I need that now and wow I'm so
glad I didn't so it's a little tiny
hacks like that can make all the
difference yeah you're absolutely right
I mean for me when I saw a bunch of
minimalists what they did is they
created these rules for themselves and
minimalism was again it was like this
common sense thing where I felt good
about bringing these rules in my life I
think for so long like I just wanted to
just act on every impulse like that's
what I thought ultimate happiness was
well if I had enough resources to act on
every impulse I have well then that must
be happiness and that is certainly not
the case I did not get nearly as you
know you could look at actually I'm not
gonna sit here and down any any public
figures but there are some public
figures out there who we know they go
away in a bond away and above and beyond
reacting on every single impulse they
have we see it on reality TV we see it
on Twitter we see it in the White House
[Music]
you can talk about it because you live
here now so it's like I'm banned no no I
wasn't even really going there but but
my point is is that you do need rules in
your life
to keep you from from falling off the
tracks and those rules they're probably
gonna look different than Josh and i's
rules are probably gonna look different
than Derek's rules but you do have to
create some rules for yourself to to
keep you to keep you from buying more
books to buy to buying clothes the only
thing to is find other things that make
you excited and that make you happy I
mean I just found out recently that like
this typical typical freaking American
I'm like this close to type-2 diabetes
I thought I had an awesome diet I
thought I'd Mariah and I we at the gym
five days a week when we're back home
and and I'm this close because my diet
isn't good enough now I do have a
genetic thing my dad has it my grandpa
had it so my body just doesn't doesn't
digest sugars as well as it should but
I've had to give up I haven't an ice
cream oh my god guys dude real fruit ice
creams you don't know what you're
missing I haven't had ice cream in like
since last year and in like I'm not I'm
not I'm not willing to you know what I
have to make choices now a bowl of ice
cream or when I rather try like a local
brew I can't have both so I have to make
choices I have to make rules for myself
but here's what's awesome is that I
swear to you you could give me a hundred
percent it's got to be the right brand
hundred percent dark chocolate bar dark
chocolate bar sorry it's like my
American right to make the hard R but
you could give me a hundred percent dark
chocolate bar it will give me the same
satisfaction of ice cream now because
what has happened is that I have cut out
the bad crap
that used to be my favorites well now
all these new things come in and they
are my favorites so if you if you are
forcing yourself to stop buying books to
stop buying clothes you got to start
asking yourself questions like well what
else excites me what else can I do that
is going to help me fill my
time instead of me sitting now now I
don't buy books and clothes anymore now
I'm just sitting on my couch wishing
that I could buy clothes and books
that's a horrible plan so create some
rules for yourself and really stick to
those but the beautiful thing is is you
get to make your own rules and while
you're here if we pass through duty-free
if you like that chocolate by Whitaker's
because it's New Zealand thanks so much
alright I will no I would have brought
some pointy I know I know mariah is
writing that down right now she is like
my wit chick is dark chocolate she's my
partner in crime when it comes to
chocolate thank you so much for your
question I know we'll have time for one
more but just in a moment first I will
move on to something we call the added
value segment of the shows where we talk
about something or some experience that
has added value to our lives recently
and since we're here in you look for
less than a day we might as well go
ahead and talk about the experiences
we've had here Ryan has anything added
value to your life while you were here
in Oakland first off you guys got some
awesome filter coffee here now I know
all right I heard someone say whoo all
right so not everyone hates filter
coffee that's good to know
there is this place I figure what street
it's on but it's it's called remedy
coffee all right someone knows about it
we have one of the air at their
employees here yes that's right
no it is so what they do is an arrow
press which is um it's the person who
invented the arrow press they wanted to
create something that would give you an
espresso type flavors but it's not an
espresso what I'm trying to talk you
guys into doing is going to remedy and
get an arrow press they've got an
Ethiopian choo-choo right now it's so
good and it's really close to an
espresso so this is like a really good
like you know baby step this is a
gateway coffee to like better filter
coffees today's podcast is brought to
you by the differences they're not
paying me and I really freaky mean it
it's an amazing shop it the great thing
about this about this segment of the
podcast is because we don't take we
refuse to take anything free like even
like the pan
that I wear I've had the company all for
like we send you free pairs that you
thought no you can't you can't send me
anything for free but then we would feel
obligated to talk about it right and in
fact I had a company send me a jacket
that I really liked for free and so I
went into the I figure out the retail
price and I donated that money to give
well.org and I sent them a receipt to
their name and to prove like you you
can't buy us with your dollars and so
whenever we get to talk about something
it becomes a experience that we actually
that we find value it yeah and we're not
embarrassed to talk about this stuff
because it it is coming from our hearts
and it is coming from actual
recommendations why I have two things
that add value in my life one is well
two things from New Zealand two things
in New Zealand one is we had breakfast
in this great place called Imperial Lane
there's like this little cafe there that
was I mean it's the best breakfast I've
had in weeks I guess I mean oh my god it
was it was just a great place and so
check it out if you get it just right
downtown Auckland and the second is
since we have Derrick here I've got to
recommend his book so so he's got a book
called anything you want and he didn't
pay me to say this this podcast is also
brought to you by me so the thing about
this what is it 88 pages yeah and and so
I've read it on the physical book I've
read the Kindle version I should read it
on the plane ride over here cuz it takes
about an hour to read but it's like life
lessons from many years of running a
business and if I were to retitle the
book or if I would have written myself I
would have just called it business
minimalism because really that's what it
is it's about getting down to being
intentional with respect to creating and
doing business because right quite often
we we hear that word business and it we
just were instantly allergic to it
because we think suit and tie corporate
guy go up to the ivory tower know it's
about solving people's problems via
creating meaningful creations and every
line like I serious if you were to see
my Kindle version of it like every
single line is like there's fewer lines
that aren't highlighted than ours
hopeful that wasn't me just highlighting
the whole book but it's also available
on an audiobook and seriously listened
to in an hour and a half on an audiobook
or if you speed it up a little bit about
an hour you know like this whole time
and like because people will ask me a
lot how do I call to Veda passionate man
how do i how do I pursue a passion and
it's really it's been really hard for me
on this stage to not ask you that
question because you do such a beautiful
job of explaining that in your book and
it would probably take you an hour and a
half to really go through the whole
story and lucky for you could buy it for
like ten bucks and it's totally worth it
the the the one thing there are two
things I'll say actually that really
stood out to me in the book the first
one was you you talk about saying no and
so whoever you write there I know who
you are yeah it is it's an it is an
amazing it's an amazing book for that it
will help you say no the other thing -
there's a line from there man that like
totally has just well it's why we have
Jess it's why we have Sean like I think
about and Josh thinks so what's the role
that we want to have as the minimalists
like what do we want to be caught up in
social media all the time so we want to
have to do this and be our own tour
manager and there are certain things
that we have to bring in help on so we
can be the absolute best at what we
really really want to do what we feel is
going to be most valuable to our
audience and in that book it helped me
to I guess to really chase that and not
feel not feel bad about you know
bringing in help
I mean we're growing but we're growing
in the right way you know
Thanks so put that on your wish list all
right move on real quick - right here
right now so we talked about what's
going on in the lives of the minimalist
so you probably saw a camera here we're
filming some new stuff for some future
projects one project that this is not
for is we are we're filming a new
documentary the talk that you saw
earlier tonight we're trying to build a
documentary around that talks that talk
is you know 30 40 minutes but but we're
trying to build a full-length talk
Documentary around aspects of that talk
so we rented out this beautiful
warehouse space in Los Angeles brought
in 300 friends and filmed this talk and
then we're gonna just go do some back
story because actually the next next
week we're headed back are now in two
weeks we're headed back to Dayton Ohio
which is where I'm from
it's the overdose capital of America but
I don't think there's a drug crisis
there so much as there is a crisis of
meaning people don't feel like they have
a purpose in what they're doing and so
they've they've turned to you the
opioids to to get the job done and
obviously they don't they don't get the
job done for long they just mask
a problem and so we're trying to help
solve that problem to a certain extent
and try to help people
REI denta fie with what their purpose is
or what brings them them joy in their
lives so that's the next thing that's
going on with us that's we tend to work
on one project the year that's gonna be
the big project as soon as this this
tour is over this is city 49 out of 50
and then we are done touring for a very
long time what's 50 Melbourne or ending
there because there's a direct flight
back to Los Angeles otherwise we would
have ended here in Auckland it just made
sense with the way we were routing
things so we're working on that
also as you know advertisements suck so
the only way that we support the podcast
we just built a new studio space in Los
Angeles and it's looking really great we
hope to add a video component so we can
do more meaningful produce more
meaningful video creations in time and
that's backed by you all so the only way
that this podcast makes any money is if
you choose and you can afford to
contribute to the podcast if you decide
you want to do that or if your listen to
this at home and you want to do that
just go to the minimalists com click
donated at the top you become a regular
supporter but you also get something
like a little bonus each week we do the
minimalists private podcast and it's
like a blow bonus up so we call it a
PostScript episode and so tonight I'd
love to record one of those in front of
you and answer a question with Derek
Siver's here y'all open for that
[Music]
beautiful let's do it all right back to
our regularly scheduled podcast so
before we wrap this up I know we're like
wait we're supposed to finish at 9:00
and it's we've steamrolled past 10:00
so I'm both sorry and you're welcome
depending on depending on where you're
at right now yeah yeah if you were one
of those people dragged here that I'm
sorry but uh here's what I'll say first
off Derrick I just want to really
acknowledge you man I know I know you
don't do this thing often and we're
grateful you decided to spend some time
with us it means a lot thank you so much
man and if you all leave here tonight
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for being
here tonight y'all thank you so much
Auckland
hey my name is Emily and I'm calling
from Frederick Maryland here's my tip
from listening to the quality podcast
keep a few crucial items like super glue
a sharpie some thread and needle a few
patches and actually some leather lotion
to extend a few of your well-worn items
more than anything I think learning
10mins
that favorite handmade sweater or pair
of boots is a great way to pay tribute
to that awesome craftsman
hi my name is Stephanie I'm calling from
Michigan and I'm calling the regard to a
woman who was on your Nashville podcast
she asked about kind of a woman's
perspective about makeup and I'm calling
with a comment for two maybe three
suggestions the first one is there's a
website in an app called stink dirty
where it will list ingredients does
makeup and kind of get a clean score
based on their chemicals and your penis
inside them so if you're looking for a
clean alternative you can scan the
makeup products that you already have
and kind of either score if you're
looking for more better alternatives
with me better ingredients they'll give
you alternatives listed and then you can
actually shop right from their app as
well my second suggestion would also be
they called hood on you and it's where
they put ecologically responsible and
animal friendly alternatives to makeup
including so you can search on their
website if you're looking for no
lipstick primer foundation or anything
like that and my third suggestion would
be if my own little personal rule is I
typically have one quality makeup item
for each you know specific area so if I
am looking for eyeliner I have one
quality eyeliner if I'm looking for my
Farrah I have one best year or two at a
time so this helps to cut down on my
makeup that way I don't have you know 17
different eyelash and shadow palettes as
well hi this is coral calling from Bend
Oregon and this is in response to your
quality episode so to me a quality
product is more than something that
lasts
time when I want to buy something new I
want the company I'm giving my money to
to have high ethical standards
so when I start my research for a new
item whether the clothing or cosmetics
or a new mattress whatever I go to the
corporation net according to their
website B Corp is to business what fair
trade certification is to coffee or USDA
Organic certification is to milk B
corpse our for-profit companies
certified by the nonprofit be lab to
meet rigorous standards of social and
environmental performance accountability
and transparency so I feel like if a
company is willing to meet those
standards they're probably a very high
quality product so I hope that you can
find what you need while making a
positive impact with your money
and minimus
you're still here it's over
go home
Oh